all right ted now to an update that we
were all anxiously waiting for earlier
this week we brought you the story of a
92 year old woman who had all four tires
from her truck stolen now we're happy to
report that new tires are on now as
victoria saha explains it's all because
of good samaritans who didn't give up
denise this is truly a story about las
vegas residents coming together to do
good for their community stepping
forward to help 92 year old marion
demario a woman they only knew through
the screens of their tv
brandon booth was adamant about helping
marion demario
after hearing about the tires of her
1995 chevy silverado truck being stolen
booth wanted to donate his tires on
wednesday but they didn't fit i was
really disappointed i really wanted to
leave like
the good ending but on thursday 8 news
now had another generous viewer come
forward and supplied the rims and new
tires
demario had no idea that the new tires
were being put on
oh my goodness
oh
oh what did you do
a little bit of help from some other
people we made it happen you re-aired
your story and gave viewers an update
that we had good samaritans wanting to
help but the tires just didn't fit
glenn reached out to us
and we worked together and made it
happen i was able to provide the wheels
nevada tire city was able to provide the
tires
and this young woman was able to provide
the labor to get it done i'm just
shocked and thankful
so thankful
demario couldn't wait to get behind the
wheel again
i just wanted to drive my truck for a
minute oh it feels so good to be driving
and her daughter who was the first to
reach out to us earlier this week for
help was there to see her mom drive away
i can't thank channel 8
and i can't thank you
and everyone there for
everything that you've done thank you so
much
you just don't know how much i
appreciate you
this truck truly had sentimental value
as demario's late husband gave it to her
as a gift almost 30 years ago we were
pulling for her ever since we heard
about the story late last week so i know
that the family had set up a gofundme
what's going on with the money that's in
that pool now so they told me that that
money is going to be reimbursed to
everyone who has donated so they can
give it to someone who needs help i
truly feel like we just made a big
project happen
and we finally got it done oh that's so
happy yeah because you know having a car
is like the keys to freedom for someone
so i'm really glad that all worked out
too still running so excited to get
behind that wheel awesome job thanks
victoria